HAPPY HOCKEY HALLOWEEN TO YOU.
IT'S THE CAPS AN
GATHERING E RUN.
THE PASS FROM HATHAWAY INT
ADVANTAGE SO FAR IN THE FIRST
THREE MINUTES.
2-0-1, 3.02.
I WOULD LIKE TO SE HAD THE ONLY
EVENING AGO FOR THE COYOTES IN
TAMPA.
HURDLELY OUT OF HIS OWN END.
VAN RIEMSDYK PICKSCORNER BOARD,R
SIDE OF CENTER
JOHN CARLSON GET
SHEARY MOTORS IN
OUT WIDE FOR WILSON.
CONNECTING THE DOTS TO
WEIRD SHOOTING ON A GOALIE THAT
CATCHES WITH THE OPPOSITE HAND,
N
THE GOAL SCOCO '18-'19 SEASON,
WITH THE CAPS.
FIRST NHL GAME PERCENTAGE
COMING IS 12.8
HIS HIGH WAS STUDIOS
BEAGLE BUMPED IMMEDIATELY BY VAN
RIEMSDYK AS SCHULTZ WILL, LOUI .
FEHERVARY WINDD ON SPRONG THAT
UNDETECTED
RIJ AT THE MORNING SKATE WERE
THINKING BACK, DURING THE CUY SZ
L
VAZ LESS SKI
RIPPED IT.
GOOD DEAD TIRED.
CAPS DIDN'T TAKE ADVANTAGE
THE Y BIRTHDAY TO MIKE GARTEK.
OVECHKIN IS THERE.
ALEX, WHO HAS POIN HIGH.
THIS IS THEIR BEST CHANCE.
MAYBE OF
MAYBE IT DID
ONE-TIMER, BLOCKED BY SHEARYARLN
AROUND AND AROUND THEY GO.
OVECHKIN TO TH